نطاق حالة تقرير الصخرة دقيقة واحدة ،
وهو أمر جيد لسماع
جوشوا هناك للسلامة العامة هناك
حساب على أربعة
خمسة خمسة أربعة محركات إشعال اثنين
واحد صفر والإقلاع
حيث يواصل العد التنازلي للمريخ
مثابرة البشرية التي
تطلق الجيل التالي من
المستكشفين الآليين إلى
لقد ذهب الكوكب الأحمر وأطلس تو لإغلاق
التحكم في الحلقة
بعد 30 ثانية من الرحلة
، يختنق محرك rd-180 لأسفل حيث
تبدو استجابة المحرك المتوقعة جيدة
، وأصبح ماخ 1 أطلس 5 الآن أسرع من الصوت
ويمر 45 ثانية في
مركبة الطيران يمر الآن من خلاله  الحد
الأقصى للضغط الديناميكي الأقصى
q وبعد ثلاث دقائق فقط من
الرحلة ، يتم الآن اختناق rd-180 للحفاظ
على حد تسارع ثابت يبلغ 2 ونصف جرام من
أجل إنصاف الحمولة النافعة
واستجابة محرك التخليص وتسريع السيارة
يبدو جيدًا